Thank you all so
much for joining us.
I'm Susan Wilson, a producer
with the Center for Art,
Science, and Technology.
As everyone knows the
pandemic has thrown all of us
into a sudden dependence
on virtual events.
We're all working together
on navigating this new world
and getting through all of the
challenges and opportunities
that it provides.
As we all continue to
iterate on the best
practices for
online events, we've
begun to transition
now from simply
trying to recreate and replace
traditional events to really
taking advantage
of a virtual format
to combine the liveness
and collaboration
that you can find in person
with the technological and
vocationally boundless
benefits of virtuality.
And I am so pleased to
introduce Tiandra Ray and Peter
Godart, who will be
sharing their experiences
and their own best practices for
virtual events with us today.
Tiandra is a 2015 graduate
of MIT in course four.
She's an architectural
designer, educator, and advocate
for restorative justice.
Peter graduated from
MIT in 2015 with degrees
in mechanical and
electrical engineering,
and is currently pursuing a
PhD in mechanical engineering,
looking at ways to use aluminum
waste to power desalinization
and produce energy.
He's also a jazz
pianist and composer.
Together they co-organized
Space for Action:
Rebuilding a Sustainable
World, a 90 minute performance
conversation in April
that brought together
leading musicians, scientists,
politicians, and activists
to reflect on how the pandemic
is reshaping our relationship
with the earth.
We're really excited to
have them with us today
to share some of their insights
from creating Space for Action
and other virtual events.
And with that, I'll turn it
over to Peter and Tiandra.
I am Tiandra Ray.
That is Peter Godart.
Thank you for the beautiful
introduction, Susan.
We are two MIT
alumni and now Peter
is back in the MIT student role,
who are currently spearheading
this collective called
Space for Action,
and it's a group of
interdisciplinary folks.
So we have artists,
we have educators,
we have musicians,
scientists, activists,
people from the Boston
community and a lot
of people from
the MIT community,
who are coming together to
curate events and exhibits
that help the public process
the large issue of our time,
which is climate change,
and how that affects
our relationships with each
other, our relationships
with the earth,
how it intersects
with various social
justice issues
and disproportionately affects
people of color in our country,
America specifically.
So we've had a lot of
success with events
in the virtual realm.
We actually didn't set out
as a virtual organization.
We had plans to actually hold
a large event and installation
at MIT this past spring
for Earth Day and of course
as the pandemic hit things
shifted a little bit.
So we had a few virtual
concerts, conversations,
talks all mixed together,
these virtual experiences
over the course of the
past several months.
And Peter is going to show us a
little bit from our performance
event.
And we had speakers
from all over.
We had Reverend
Mariama White-Hammond,
who is a local
minister and climate
activist in the Boston area.
We had representative
Ayanna Pressley there.
We had Bill McKibben and
we had Esperanza Spalding,
which was really exciting.
So she did some music, some
speaking, and we also brought
in some MIT alumni and some
Berklee professors and alumni
to do some original
compositions.
So Peter, do you want
to show us those clips?
Yeah and before I do,
so to accomplish all
that Tiandra said that
we're trying to accomplish
as an organization,
Space for Action,
the most important thing for
us are holding these events,
these engaging events,
where it's a conversation
and it's also educational.
And so we spent a
lot of time thinking
about how to accomplish
this in a virtual setting.
And so what I'm
about to show you
are some clips from
our most recent event.
And so what I want
you to look out for
is just the diversity
in terms of content
and in terms of communities
that we're engaging with,
as well as how the
talks and performances
flow and transition from
one end to the other.
And note that there was a
breakout session in here
that I will not be showing.
But aside from that just take
it all in and take some notes.
We'll discuss this
after I show you.
(SINGING) Come together
all you parts of me.
Scattered and carried by wind
and wave to distant lands.
Let us remember that wholeness
is our natural state.
We will now hear from Edmar
Colon and Tutti Druyan.
Edmar is a saxophonist,
pianist, and composer
from Puerto Rico,
who is currently
on the faculty of the
Berklee College of Music.
Tutti is a singer, songwriter,
actor, and voiceover artist,
and they have both
performed worldwide.
Today, they will be performing
Somewhere over the Rainbow.
So it is my pleasure
to introduce my dear
friends, Tutti and Edmar.
(SINGING) Somewhere
over the rainbow.
Good evening, I say to you,
recognizing that for some of us
this actually is a
statement of faith.
To say that it is a good
evening means to imagine and let
go of some of the
anxiety that we feel.
We have an opportunity
here, an obligation,
to build a more
equitable future.
And I'm so grateful
for all of you
frontliners, you
community builders,
to be your sister in solidarity
and actualizing that vision.
And for those that don't get
it I have great confidence
in your powers of persuasion
and influence and storytelling
to bring others along.
Thank you.
Our next special guest is
a true force of nature,
thus since the
inception of her career
has been propelling her field
forward with mighty speed
and depth, while inspiring
many to explore their highest
potential as artists
and human beings.
Please help me virtually welcome
Grammy award-winning artists
and big advocate for climate
and natural environment,
and paraphrasing from
Reverend Mariama's words,
I get to call her
my dear friend,
my sister, Esperanza Spalding.
(SINGING) I'm out,
the house of worship.
Rife with pride,
rife with doctrine.
Rife with sin, now
my laptop or device
is where I shop for wisdom.
At my very fingertips so
much more than some holy man
could ever hope to comprehend.
So maybe now the
holy spirit is simply
a mighty network anchored
in accumulated knowledge.
Now encompassing the globe.
(SINGING) Heal our heart.
Be like the drum, loud and sure.
Feel the life rush through
our veins, cool and pure.
Now the oneness of our
spirit shall endure.
Say oh yeah, oh yeah, come.
Oh, man.
It's really hard to stop
a lot of those clips.
But that was just a
couple of snippets.
If you would like to see
the whole thing in full,
it's up on YouTube.
I'm happy to share
that with you.
You'll get our
contact information
at the end of this presentation.
But to make this
engaging we're hoping
that for this next
part, if you're able,
we're going to send you
all into breakout rooms.
We hope that, if
you're able, you
can share your video
and unmute yourselves
and in groups of
about five or so,
we would like you to answer
these two questions, talk
about these two questions
for about 10 minutes or so.
And then we'll reconvene
and discuss and try
to coalesce your responses.
All right.
Welcome back everybody.
So now we are going to
talk about these questions
as a group.
We'll call on a
couple representatives
from each breakout room
to discuss some insights
that you came up with.
And we're going to use
this jam board to document
some of these responses.
So I know, Stacy, you
were taking some notes.
I'm going to cold call on
you to maybe kick us off.
Yeah.
Sure.
I did take some notes.
So we talked about
first what makes
an in-person event so special.
We talked about how
you can see people more
and you get more nonverbal cues.
I did mention that
at MIT there's
usually snacks and
beverages, which is a plus.
There's a networking
aspect and it feels
a little bit more collegial.
Multiple people can be
talking or discussing
something at the same time.
And you can move around
the physical space
instead of sitting in
front of a screen, which
I think helps a little
bit with event fatigue.
And then moving into
successful versus
unsuccessful online events.
We talked a lot about practicing
and rehearsing and making sure
that your presenters
understand the technology,
having a really professional
run sheet and tech backups
and the more freeform things
are, the more stressful
they can become.
We also talked about how
it's really important
to understand the attention
span of most people.
You can't really have
an hour lecture in zoom.
And with that we
wanted to provide
an opportunity for
people to interact
and we noted that breakout rooms
are really effective for that.
We've had some success across
multiple different departments
with different types
of icebreaker or games
where people get
to know each other
and interact a little bit.
And then we talked
about how if you're
kind of planning your one-off
show, if you have something
a little surprising and
something kind of engaging
in an other
discussion points, you
can have actually a
really engaging meeting.
So those were our points.
Great.
Marion or Shannon
Rose, anything to add?
No.
That was a pretty
comprehensive representation.
Thanks Stacy.
Thank you.
Cool.
So anyone from the
other room, would you
like to share some insights
as to these two questions?
I was nominated, so I will share
our insight at room number two.
We had a lot of overlap in
what was discussed just now.
I would say successful
in-person events,
some things that we
discussed that have not yet
been mentioned are the
cultivation of atmosphere
in in-person events
and what an impact that
makes on your experience
as an audience.
We also talked a little bit
about other people, generally.
But I would classify,
rather than networking,
what we talked about
more as intimacy,
like noticing other things
that other people are saying,
reacting to stimulus
with other people,
having conversations that are
spontaneous and spontaneity is
like another successful
in-person event trademark,
I think.
The ability to be spontaneous
in the conversation
that you're having.
In direct opposition
to that, it was
Heidi that mentioned how
successful virtual events need
to have some sort of
a moderator or agenda.
If everyone's talking at
once and it's sort of a free
for all, it's really
difficult to have a meaningful
conversation because you
literally cannot hear each
other speak because the audio
won't take multiple inputs
at the same time.
I personally just
find it really hard
to have conversations
on Zoom for that reason
because so much of
my conversation style
is like spitballing.
So I find it really hard to
talk to people on Zoom the way
that I would normally speak.
Another element of
successful virtual events
that we talked about
was interactivity,
which Stacey mentioned.
We were talking about how
having an interactive element
makes it easier to pay
attention and feel engaged
in the online meeting
that you're in,
which can be really nice.
I think that that's
pretty much everything
that diverged from
what Stacy mentioned.
Am I missing anything?
Maybe Heidi or Lydia could
chime in, or Catherine.
The spontaneity part,
I would just add,
we talked about
running into people,
which is harder to do
when you're on Zoom,
just the spontaneity of being
out and about at like a Boston
theatre performance and
seeing someone you know well
or someone you don't know well.
But I guess it happens sometimes
on Zoom but not as much.
Totally.
Well, I'm super impressed.
You all are experts on
virtual events, it seems.
At least you've been to
enough good and bad ones
to know the difference.
So I'm just going to try to--
you've all touched on
all of these things
that I'm about to tell
you, but our philosophy
with our event, which you
know we got good feedback on.
And I tried to distill a lot of
the feedback that we'd received
and it was very much
in line with what
we were all discussing here.
But to kind of distill those
into three guiding principles.
We would put them into
these three categories.
Brevity, keep things
short, keep things moving.
As you all mentioned,
attention spans
are low especially when
you're staring at a screen.
You're not up and about
and moving around.
And so it's best to avoid long
lectures wherever possible
with only a couple of speakers.
So if you are going
to be introducing
a lot of spoken
or verbal content,
it's good to either switch
back and forth between people
or just have as many
speakers as possible.
The second guiding principle
would be diversity.
So it's super important
to include varied content
and also varied representation
from different groups.
The representation
from different groups
is key because
different speakers
are going to be engaging to
different groups of people.
And so you want to have
content for everyone
that you expect to be on the
call and maybe even some people
you don't expect.
And then the third
point is continuity.
So no matter what you're
doing, try to tell a story,
maintain a clear theme, and
transitions in particular
are key.
And a couple of Zoom tips.
And again, these are
all basically things
that people mentioned.
We found that it was really
good to avoid the webinar
style of events, where there's
this extra layer of anonymity,
where you can't even see the
people who are on the call.
It's nice to have
names and faces,
and especially as
a performer, it's
really nice to look
out to your Zoom screen
and kind of imagine an audience.
Seeing all the
squares is actually
very inspiring to a performer.
Have a script and
practice the transitions,
including sharing a screen.
We've all been on
these Zoom meetings
where people don't know
how to share their screen,
or unmute themselves, et cetera.
Mistakes obviously happen, but
just try to be prepared there.
Frequent use of breakout rooms
and just encouraging people
to show video and keeping
them engaged at various points
throughout, obviously
is a great idea.
For musicians, it's
extremely important
to set up the audio correctly.
So there are all these
advanced audio settings
that turn off the
Zoom algorithms,
which are optimized for speech,
and in particular this option
called turn on original
sound, which just takes
your raw input from
the microphone, which
is great for live instruments.
As someone mentioned
in our group, at least,
it's important to have a
moderator in any large group
discussions.
People can't be
trusted to sort of self
organize when there's
20 or so people.
People are going to
talk over one another,
and then the best
case scenario is
that everyone is just silent.
So it's good to break it
up into smaller groups,
or if it is a larger group,
obviously, have a moderator.
Using a team and spreading
out responsibilities
is extremely helpful.
You can have someone
managing break out rooms,
someone speaking,
and someone sitting
idle ready to unmute the person
who forgot to mute themselves
and is yelling at their dog,
which literally happened to us.
And in general just be positive
and embrace the format.
Obviously, it's
not a live event,
and I think there
are some benefits
to doing virtual events so just
try to embrace those benefits.
And by the way, I will be
sharing these slides so
don't feel like you have to
take notes on all of this.
I'd be happy to share
this afterwards.
So, Tiandra, do you want to
talk about some things that are
on Zoom, which are pretty cool?
Yes.
So we all know and love
Zoom at this point,
or well complicated
relationship with Zoom maybe.
But we all have interacted
with this format
and are interacting with it
now, but there are definitely
ways to enhance
the Zoom experience
by adding in elements that
go beyond just the video.
And just to give
you a little preview
of what Peter and I have been
cooking up with the SFA team.
We're thinking about physical
installations that are
interactive via a stream,
more interactive from afar
and thinking about how we
organize people in outdoor
spaces, but streaming it so that
it is accessible to people who
cannot access the
outdoor spaces and again,
different ways of interactivity
virtually that is not just us
having a conversation and
interacting with physical built
space, which is
really interesting.
But I want to point out
a couple of other tools
that we've interacted with
in the last few months.
So High Fidelity is
an interesting tool.
I think it was Heidi that
mentioned in our group enjoying
just bumping into people
and being able to hear
a conversation from afar.
So what High Fidelity does is
it places everybody on a map
that you design, like a map of
the space, and it's a 2D map.
And Peter, you could click
on that link I think,
not the picture, the caption.
It takes you to that page.
So you're actually just a
floating head on this map
and you actually hear
in your headphones
the people talking around
you, depending on where
your icon is on the map.
So Peter and I attended this
birthday party festival thing,
where they use this and
it was pretty interesting.
There are definitely
some kinks to work out
in terms of not being awkward,
but when you're with friends,
I think it especially
is helpful when you're
with a group of people
that you already
have some familiarity with.
But the points on the map can be
linked to do different things.
So we talked about, whether you
could link a portion of the map
to a Zoom meeting.
So you go to a mini
breakout room and just
interesting things like that.
They mapped it to a
series of Google photos
from different past events
to make people feel nostalgic
and hid a scavenger
hunt inside of there.
So there are lots of different
options for interaction there.
And then there are
tools like MURAL
boards or the Jamboard
that you just saw,
which are great for
collaborative brainstorming.
And of course
there's the whatever
you all decide to come up with
in your innovative, creative
capacities.
So we want to have a quick
second breakout session
and I'll post the questions
in the chat, where
we take some time to
actually brainstorm,
think about what we can
do with what we have
and specific to all of your
fields and spheres of influence
and communities and
preferences here at MIT.
And actually in the spirit
of improvisation and adapting
to time constraints,
we're actually
not going to break out.
We're just going to have
this discussion amongst us,
so if you want to turn on
your cameras right now.
We'll just have this
discussion straight up.
So if you want to speak, just
because there's few more of us
than in previous
breakout rooms, either
raise your hand physically
or use the raise hand feature
and I'll just call on you.
And the questions
are in the chat,
so Peter you can take
that off the screen
if you want so we
can see each other.
All right Question one,
what types of events
do you imagine
organizing this semester
and what do they encompass?
So are you thinking audio,
visual, conversation, music,
et cetera?
I'll go.
I am going to be
doing all of that.
I oversee the art
scholars and the grad arts
forum and the creative
arts competitions,
so I'm going to be
doing virtual gallery
tours, virtual live streamed
concerts with Zoom talkbacks,
including conversation.
I'm going to be doing
workshop style classes
on business fundamentals.
I'm going to be doing a
pitch finale event that's
sort of like Shark Tank.
I'm pretty much going
to be doing anything
that you can
imagine encompassing
non-curricular education
and trying to replicate
some modicum of a
shared musical or arts
experience with conversation.
Love it.
Doing it all.
Marion, Marion I
saw your hand up.
Yes.
So I'm with the program in
Art, Culture, and Technology.
And we're going to have
our lecture series online
and I was very interested
in the non webinar component
because the thing that
we're being sold on
is that when you
do it virtually you
can have thousands
of people meet
or at least hundreds of people.
So it looks like we're tiptoeing
towards the webinar style,
but that won't really facilitate
the kind of engagement.
Although many would
argue that there
isn't much engagement
at our lecture series,
but you didn't
hear that from me.
So I would be very
curious to hear about what
your suggestions are.
Great.
Susan.
I just wanted to
really quickly--
I think one of the things
that I found really powerful
about the fix for action
thing in the spring
was that we did have
the full audience.
I think one of the
things that I was talking
about with a student
in our breakout group
was you lose that energy in
Zoom between the performer
and the audience member.
And I think that really
affects performers,
and I think as an
audience member we
just kind of check
out more easily
because we're used
to being a little bit
visible in an audience space.
If you fall asleep
you eventually
feel embarrassed, usually.
There's a bit more
responsibility to the moment
and what I really loved about
the end of that section,
especially when there was
so much community discussion
and engagement with the song and
the spirit of the whole thing,
is that we did have
everybody on camera.
I mean most people were
on camera the whole time.
And it was really powerful to be
able to scroll through and just
see people experiencing the
same thing that you were
and I recall hearing from the
artists involved in that piece
as well that it made a
difference to see people
watching you as
opposed to just looking
at your own self in the
camera the whole time.
And I think those things
were really powerful
and made a big difference.
It was a small thing that
I think had a huge impact.
We spent so much time
thinking about what
would engage our
audience, but it's also
important to engage the speakers
and the performers as well.
And like Susan said, the
quality of the performance
goes way up when people feel
that pressure and that support.
So any last thoughts?
Anyone else planning
events or have
some new ideas for some events
they would like to see even?
This is not a specific
event that I'm planning,
but I am always
thinking about ways
to make events that
combine, as Dana was talking
about in our breakout room,
some sort of gathering
but also a lot of
interactive parts and games,
so not necessarily-- somewhere
in between a group of friends
getting together to play
a game and a live streamed
performance.
I think there would be a really
cool niche in the middle there,
which I you guys achieved with
this Space for Action event.
But this idea of incorporating
both interactivity
and performance
in the same space.
No specific ideas
for that, but I
have been brainstorming
a little bit.
I love it.
Let's make it happen.
Any last thoughts?
At this point, we can also just
open it up to general questions
you might have for us about
our Space for Action events
or how we're thinking
about things these days.
I also want to give a huge
shout out to Susan and Heidi
for the Space for Action event.
They both contributed
a lot of content,
so I'm happy to see you here
and it's awesome that you
helped make it what it was.
It was really cool.
Any last thoughts here?
I know we're kind of
bumping up on our time but.
I have a quick
question, actually.
Yeah.
How much of the Space
for Action content
was prerecorded versus live?
It was 100% live.
100% live?
Amazing.
Digital recording.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Risky, especially that
first piece, which we
kind of slipped in last
minute to have the drum
and beats coming from
one place and Peter
turning on the piano
from another place
and Ricky singing so.
I'd encourage from that
for everyone to experiment,
push the boundaries.
You don't have to be
afraid of the lag.
As musicians like
you can make it--
there are definitely
certain things
you can't do but get creative
and innovative with it.
And I think Marion you were
talking about the lecture
series and creating something
that's more engaging.
Well, maybe that means that you
reimagine the lecture series
and it's no longer
just a lecture.
But it's more of an
interactive conversation
and it's not just the person
speaking and then Q&A.
But maybe it's something
that reads differently.
If people are open
to actually pushing
that boundary at this point.
That is the question.
And I will say we had a lot of--
But a great idea.
--We had people
like Bill McKibben,
Esperanza Spalding, Rep.
Ayanna Presley,
and people really
felt like they were on a
Zoom call with these people
because they literally were.
They felt like that you
were in a very small room.
It was very intimate with these
just like incredible people
you would not have access
to in any other setting.
And we could have definitely
asked for prerecorded input
from each of these
artists and speakers,
but we really didn't want that.
We took the risk and
just went for full live.
And yeah I'd encourage you
all to take that risk as well.
And they interacted
with each other, which
was really beautiful, too.
In allowing that
mix, the panel model
almost works more
in this context
because it's not just one person
talking but you can jump off
of each other.
So before we wrap up here, I am
going to share this last slide
with everybody.
And I would encourage, you
can take a screenshot of this.
And this is our information
for Space for Action.
And if you're interested
in our organization
and want to get involved,
this is the information
that you would need to do so.
So we're planning some
hopefully in-person events
when this is all over.
But definitely some more virtual
events until that happens.
And we'd love to just engage
more people so hit us up.
Peter and Tiandra,
thank you so much.
This was such a
wonderful workshop.
It was great to hear
more about this reaction
and I think it was really
an exciting conversation.
We can't wait to have more
online events and then
in-person ones.
We're very excited
about that, too.
Everyone please stick around.
Arts on the Radar continues.
So the ACT gallery opening
will be starting at 5:00
and we're thrilled
about that as well.
We have an exciting night.
And thanks to Susan, Lydia,
and Shannon Rose for helping
put all this together.
This is fun for us as well.
Thank you.